right like if you're raising children
okay we can have a conversation about
that but it seems like the vast majority
of the time it's a matter of convenience
I don't really want to drive that far
you know to see her or she doesn't have
a car or we can save a little bit of
money if we live together blah blah blah
like you know it's like these
convenience right complicate life
justify why those four words don't ever
forget them think them through
never live with your significant other
unless you're married don't over invest
by volunteering to do tasks only a
husband is obligated to do is what this
dude said
um Pro sex was available cons my
development stopped this popped up a lot
too a lot of guys said that they stop
essentially they
they said something along the lines of I
stopped chasing Excellence right because
she now lives with you right your your
entire world because a lot of guys make
her their entire world it's all about
her right whatever I can do to please
her she's you know she's my best friend
she's my sunshine she's my rainbows blah
blah blah [ __ ] [ __ ] right and they
don't maintain a purpose they don't
chase Excellence they have chased her
they got her
and now it's time to retire and it's not
a good it's not a good move it's not a
good look on you fellows
um it always almost always leaves leads
to
um her losing interest in you I'm going
to talk about again these four points
which is competition anxiety betaization
frame and legal issues were the four
main ones that I want to cover which I
think are important I'll get into those
in a bit
um I just kind of highlighted the ones I
wanted to read here's one uh so this guy
ralbatross says she lost interest in me
she became less tolerant she became even
rude in some cases I had to remind more
and more frequently I had to remind more
and more frequently her place and warn
her about her behavior
sometimes the language doesn't make any
sense uh she even confessed one day it's
normal to have low desire after three to
four months of living together well okay
maybe in your friends lives well one
month after hearing this I broke up with
her I was in love breaking up was one of
the most difficult right things to do
now I'm keeping the girlfriend as a
proximity inviting her to my place and
reminding her okay so he must have moved
into her place the way that he worded
that so he's saying that he's inviting
her to my place and reminding her this
is my place and she's a guest much
better I think we must keep the ladies
in that limbo to get the best out of
them
so there's some truth to that which
becomes evident when you read all 450
comments which I did before doing this
show it's a bit exhausting but I you
know I go through these exercises to
make sure that I I have
everything I need to talk about if you
want to read them all Community tab of
the unplugged Alpha podcast on YouTube
communities have entrepreneurs and cars
on YouTube
um entrepreneurs and cars on Facebook
and the Twitter post you'll find them
all there 450 comments from all these
guys it's very very common and it seems
like one of the things that became
evident anyway is that women will always
behave better when they're in the
girlfriend State versus the live-in
girlfriend State they always say
girlfriends are better than wives and
essentially if you have a chick move in
she essentially becomes that like wife
even though you don't get married
I mean the way the state sees it in most
cases anyways is common law you know
like you're basically you know together
in that sense
um even though you don't have you know
make like an official ceremony but it's
true you know
um there there has to be some
competition anxiety for her to feel
um her best ability and I'm gonna talk
about that in a bit let me go through a
few more of these over here
let's see if I got any more highlights
on this page
there's one
um
actually I'll skip that one
let's go over to this is tab it does
okay beautiful
okay so this is a positive one over here
um hang on Boom so this guy had great
things to say he says going on nine
years and wouldn't have it any other way
our personalities work out seamlessly
together there's no arguments we're both
self-employed she enjoys the flu sorry
she enjoys the fruits of her labor and I
enjoy mine I got her in the cars and she
got me into having a dog we look forward
to doing things together and also having
mutual respect for each other's separate
interests in time the only con is a
place isn't as tidy as it would be if I
took care of it myself but for how great
everything is after the better part of a
decade so we're talking like close to 10
years here right I feel even silly
calling that a con because the place
looks lived in and loved I understand
how many uh out there become jaded and
even being in a relationship let alone
living together after all Society has
been increasing State of Decay for many
years by design by the way this guy
understands the product of that is
rotten people the trick is to break away
from the sick experiment and find
like-minded people don't look for a
girlfriend in social media or dating
apps so
an honest positive opinion from this
gentleman
Robin
who's somehow made it work for 10 years
for him which is you know good for him
there's a bunch of replies here no kids
then where would you look for a
girlfriend that's what I'm saying
passport Bros what's this passport Bros
the passport Bros again eh
okay yeah these are all Spam comments
you're going to get those from time to
time on YouTube
um this guy Randolph said she was an
excellent cook took it upon herself to
buy and prepare amazing meals all the
time but she was negative about my
vehicle buying and even though she
wouldn't hesitate to ask to drive it
when I got home yeah
criticizing your spending habits seemed
like a Common Thread thing you know what
you spend your money on but then
taking taking up the opportunity to
utilize what you spend your money on
right
bought a hot tub put a pool in bought a
new car criticized you but then used it
you know willingly and enjoy you know
enjoyably
she's gone now and I have an amazing
Fleet of eight different vehicles I
sought out over the years dude's happy
good for you right
um that was by the way one of the things
that popped up in the negative side
actually the main negatives that I saw
pop a lot were fighting
loss of privacy nagging and bitching
uh uh bad with money popped up quite a
few times meaning she would move in but
not end up paying like he thought she
would she would lose her job lose hours
one of the things I noticed too is a lot
of women like to
um
try to negotiate what they're going to
contribute to the household whether
you're renting or bought it I mean
buying is a different can of worms
you're inviting legal issues in but
so let's say you're a dude you're making
200 000 a year with a chick she makes
seventy eight thousand dollars a year a
lot of time a lot of the time you'll see
these women will be like well since I
don't make as much money as you and the
rents you know two thousand dollars then
I should really only pay in proportion
to what I make right now they'll pull
that with a dude but they won't pull
that [ __ ] off with like a girlfriend or
something like that right like
that's just how it that's just how the
cookie crumbles you know you are going
to find yourself in situations from time
to time where it's like well you know
you make a lot more money so why don't
you pay more of the rent or you just pay
all of the rent and I'll buy some
grocery sort of things
that popped up a few times too you're
gonna get that from time to time so
there was uh money issues uh loss of
your hobbies and the other thing which
was admitted many many times was
intimacy diminishes pretty consistently
across the board in some cases it was
rapidly
um there was many guys that talked about
being cheated on as well I got a couple
you know that I copied and pasted over
here my word doc that I want to get into
as well too which
um I think I pulled most of those off
Twitter let me just mute this damn thing
um
this guy over here said I live with my
ex-temper as a temporary solution so
some like sometimes it might make sense
as a temporary solution to live with you
know a girlfriend
um your house is under construction
you're you've got 60 days closing you've
got a you're in limbo from one place to
the next place
um that it might make sense to
temporarily live with her but in that
case like you're living in her house
anyway so all the prior problems that I
talked about with frame are of course
going to come up but anyway this guy
lives in a temporary solution because
she had issues with her sister and
needed to move out so it sounds like in
this case she moved into his place what
was supposed to be a few weeks turned
into a full-time cohabitation plus sorry
the plus was segs obviously in
companionship and she would cook and
clean off the downside was that I had to
pay extra for things it only started to
bother me because when she started
working her money was hers and suddenly
she had a family in her country of
origin to take care of
so she moves into dude's place
isn't making contributions and all of a
sudden sending her money back home
that's happened to a few guys
another downside was I couldn't spin
plates or have time to myself no more
and ultimately she started pressuring me
in a marriage I had to end it and ask
her to move out if you aren't ready to
settled down for a short period fall and
moving in together don't do it
reasonable advice
uh this guy over here spotted T says I
started doing house chores because she
didn't know how to keep a house imagine
that modern woman doesn't know how to
keep a house that's incredible she saw
me in a different light and she ended up
cheating on me shortly after I started
doing chores that ties into the Beta
cization through a thousand thousand
concessions that I want to talk about in
a moment
uh I'll get to that when I get to my
four main points I just wanted to
highlight some of these okay so those
are the main ones off of that and let me
just throw this word doc up because I
copied and pasted some of the other ones
from Facebook and some of the other
sources too so uh stop screen
and share
and where is it there it is Boom okay
um Pro full sex access Con held in too
many farts
I had to share with that one I thought
it was funny
I dated this uh didn't date sorry I went
out on one date with this chick once
and halfway through the day she
proceeded to tell me that she has no
tolerance for men that fart
all men fart I said really so what would
you expect a guy to do I would expect
him to get up and go to the bathroom and
close the door and fart in the bathroom
I was like you're going to be an old
miserable lady I hope you like cats
um this guy over here Matt Cowell says I
lived in a sea can in Afghanistan for
705 days was six to nine men never one
fight ever then he goes on to say I
lived in a 4 000 square foot house with
one woman and it's some and it's
sometimes a nightmare
reasonable point this guy Legion says
Pros uh more intimacy more often you get
to know what she's liked in All Seasons
it's if she can cook that's nice you'll
notice ladies if you're watching this
podcast men appreciate a woman with
culinary skills it's appreciated you
notice this so far it's one of the
things that seems to pop up quite a lot
Beyond just intimacy is they appreciate
a woman that feeds
difficult concept for a lot of modern
women today to understand of course so
but you know
I got Uber Eats I'm going to order you
some ubereats I'm going to do some
drive-through pickup I don't want to eat
that [ __ ] hey guys I really hope that
you enjoyed that short clip if you did
consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unpluggedalpha.com forward
slash shop when you click through you'll
be able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational Essentials
for health immune Health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code Alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the Subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching I
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out